all right midnight deadline to file your
2018 taxes just moments away and thanks
to President Trump the majority of
Americans will be keeping more of their
hard-earned money due to the historic
tax reform now that's despite by the way
the absolute lies told by the liberal
media and certain Democrats what they're
doing is dishonest in terms of telling
the middle class or getting a tax hike
but in fact you're getting ripped off
ten years out 60% of Americans will see
their taxes go up because of this bill
and it's the lower 60% of Americans who
would have thought they could have made
the bill even less favorable to the
middle class and more slanted towards
the wealthy this tax cut would help
millions of people they met people with
millions Colbert that economics PhD well
the echo-chamber of negative news on the
Trump tax cuts is having an impact on
the voters well according to a new
Gallup poll 49% apparently disapprove of
the president's tax bill 40% approved
and that's the highest approval for the
measure since Gallup started measuring
reaction but finally there is some
pushback to the lies and now even the
liberal New York Times admits it was
wrong writing quote the gap between
perception and reality on the tax cuts
appears to flow from a sustained and
misleading effort by liberal opponents
of the law
to brand it as a broad middle-class tax
increased ha joining me now White House
National Economic Council director Larry
Kudlow Larry how much is the average
American saving this year about $2,300
that is a big number average families
$75,000 a year will save $2,300 that is
a very big number businesses are gonna
save huge amounts of money not just big
businesses but medium and small
businesses which may be driving the
economy right now with the most
incredible drop in unemployment in 50
years across the spectrum all matter
Ardi groups including women who were the
biggest job gainers last year could you
argue that the administration might not
have done the best job on selling what
this tax cut would do from the beginning
to have that poll number for this
economy where it is and small business
owners calling me friend of Mines an
accountant over Maryland said thank you
president Trump I just got an extra I
think it's like three or four thousand
dollars this year because this tax cut I
mean those stories are everywhere and
yet look at that polls still pretty lame
so okay let's look at this
Trump policies lower taxes deregulation
opening up energy good trade deals we
are in a rising tide of prosperity his
policies are rebuilding the economy now
all right
polls let's look at polls 58% Harvard
Harris Georgetown or George Washington
back battleground poll and NBC Wall
Street Journal
58% believe we are in a positive
prosperous economies by the way Bernie
Sanders tonight was on with Martha and
Brett and he said you all don't get any
credit for this economy Larry let's
watch do you know what unemployment is
in Germany now 3.1 percent in Japan it's
2.8 percent in the UK it's a hair higher
than us in other words the entire global
economy thank God is bouncing back for
the terrible terrible wall street
disaster the global economy is coming
back and unemployment is relatively low
now I know Trump will give a slightly
different spin on it he said well the
president's trying to take all the
credit he that basically doesn't deserve
it your reaction to that the real truth
of the g7 versus listen the g7 is nearly
in recession
you can argue Germany he mentioned
Germany I don't get that Germany is
either flat or in a recession the
eurozone flatter in a recession China
slumping we are the hottest economy in
the world growing three percent or
better with a 3.8 percent unemployment
rate with wages rising this Sanders
neglects this the biggest beneficiaries
are the blue-collar workers not the
supervisors
we've never seen blue-collar employment
like this in 50 years the wage rates are
above 3% but in that cohort okay look at
overall wages the biggest gainers the
blue-collar non-supervisory workers he
is precisely wrong and I'll go back to
this point 58% believe that we are an
economic prosperity for Trump's policies
you know tax cuts are a means to an end
what about the debt twenty ten twenty
two trillion dollars and is jobs a
killer
I mean we're adding huge spending on to
this economy we will grow at better than
3% in our estimates that is the best
measure to bring down deficits President
Trump also has the toughest budget he's
put up five percent cuts in domestic
side if the so called spending caps are
not met guess what we are going to
sequester across-the-board
bring back the sequester footage edge
what do you know gramm-rudman yo grab
everybody hates the sequester I'm glad
ten percent across the president is
gonna be as the toughest budget use next
year better growth better growth more
limited government that will help on
that side you think a Buddha judge out
there talking about that how Trump is
trying to capture the middle of America
but it's selling basically fear and a
bygone era that's never coming back what
do you make of that you know President
Trump is gonna win middle America
this is gonna be listen to this old
Reagan guy may I've seen this before
this is gonna be the biggest economic
big tent you've ever seen you go down
the list african-americans Asians
White's
adult men and women teenagers the
unemployment rates are so low and the
wages have improved so much at the lower
end that they are going to come into the
Trump Democrats freak out are they
freaking out right now yeah because
they're gonna leave all the hard hats
all the construction guys were building
pipelines we're opening up trade deals
that are gonna have farm much I'm not
crazy they'll they're China's gonna be
promises or we don't make the deal if
it's not cuz I'll be coming after you
biggest winners in that will be farmers
and ranchers okay ordinary we gotta go
but it see us MCAD little Bernie Bernie
is I gotta tell you let's do it one last
one senator Sanders okay to go three I'm
sorry 180 million Americans will lose
their private insurance under Sanders he
will take out 15 percent of the GDP
inside of ten years at the very moment
where we have a new prosperity cycle
from Trump policies he wants to turn it
back into a deep recession that is nuts
that is just crazy Larry cut lasting
economic big-tent that's coming good to
see it my friend now you are